There aren't all that many good movies based
on video games, but maybe that's just because
the right adaptation hasn't come along yet.
Video games are more cinematic and visually
impressive now than ever before, and their
popularity means that Hollywood is continuing
to try and find ways of turning major video
game franchises into major movie franchises.
Let us know which ones you want to see in
the comments below!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Video Games We Want
To See On Film.
Fallout
We've all seen action movies where the hero
shows up just in time to prevent nuclear bombs
being dropped on the United States.
Well, the Fallout series is set in a world
where that hero never showed up.
What makes the Fallout games particularly
good source material for a movie adaptation
isn't so much the story, but the setting.
When the dust clears, America is a blasted
wasteland occupied by small pockets of life
including bandits, monsters, slavers, weird
cults, military factions like the Enclave
and the Brotherhood of Steel, and a whole
lot of regular people just trying to scratch
a living.
For the right filmmaker, this world could
be the perfect backdrop for an original story
set in the Fallout universe.
BioShock
Atmospheric 2007 shooter BioShock sends the
player to the ocean floor, where a group of
scientists, industrialists and artists have
built their own vision of utopia, only to
have their new civilization collapse into
chaos and horror.
With its Art Deco aesthetic and watery surroundings,
Rapture is a production designer's dream,
and the city's rich backstory and horrifying
denizens are perfect for the big screen.
In fact, several years ago a movie adaptation
was in development at Universal with Gore
Verbinski set to direct.
Unfortunately, Verbinski's insistence on an
R rating and Universal's concerns about the
budget meant that BioShock was put on the
back burner, where it's remained ever since.
Silent Hill 2
There have already been two movies based on
the Silent Hill games - one of them pretty
good, the other pretty terrible.
These movies were based on the first Silent
Hill game and Silent Hill 3, which deal with
the town's strange cult and the little girl
who becomes a vessel for their god.
Silent Hill 2, however, is about a man called
James Sunderland who comes to Silent Hill
after his wife sends a letter inviting him
to the town.
He finds this pretty disturbing, since his
wife has been dead for three years.
It's a great set-up for a game full of mystery,
psychological horror and creepy monsters - all
of which could transfer very well to the big
screen.
Borderlands
Anyone who's seen a Mad Max movie will easily
be able to spot the direct influence of those
films in Borderlands, Gearbox Software's colorful,
cel shaded open world role-playing shooter.
The alien planet of Pandora is a dangerous
wasteland and pretty much everyone who lives
there is insane, but that's all part of its
charm.
The plot of the games is follows groups of
fortune seekers who are trying to track down
mysterious Vaults full of immensely powerful
alien technology, and we'd love to see a filmmaker
tackle both the offbeat humor and the treasure-hunting
quest at the heart of the Borderlands series.
Deus Ex
With prosthetic limbs becoming ever more advanced,
the world of cyberpunk shooter series Deus
Ex is starting to seem like a realistic vision
of the future.
As human beings start to use technology to
evolve their own biology, the player is faced
with some hard choices regarding what the
future of the human race should look like,
and how it should be governed.
The original Deus Ex is still the pinnacle
of the series, but Deus Ex: Human Revolution
was the title that really demonstrated just
how great a movie adaptation could look.
Middle-earth: Shadow of Mordor
Peter Jackson's take on The Hobbit didn't
quite live up to the standards set by the
Lord of the Rings trilogy, but an adaptation
of Middle-earth: Shadow of Mordor could be
a great addition to the movie canon.
The game takes place after the events of The
Hobbit but before The Lord of the Rings, and
focuses on a Ranger called Talion, who is
killed by Sauron's forces but is saved when
a wraith merges with his body, turning Talion
into an undead warrior with some very unique
abilities.
Enraged by the slaughter of his family, Talion
proceeds to single-handedly wreak havoc on
Sauron's army of Orcs, playing an unsung role
in preventing the fall of Middle-earth.
inFAMOUS
Given the current Hollywood craze for comic
book movies, now is the perfect time for a
movie version of inFAMOUS.
This open world game casts players as Cole
McGrath, a bike courier who gains electricity-based
superpowers when he's caught at the center
of a devastating explosion.
After the smoke clears, Cole is faced with
the choice to either become a superhero and
save the citizens of Empire City, or use his
powers to become a supervillain and make people
fear and despise him.
No matter which path you pick, this is one
comic book style video game that we definitely
want to see on film.
The Wolf Among Us
Based on the Fables comic books by Bill Willingham,
The Wolf Among Us is a cool, noir detective
story with a fantasy twist.
When characters from fairy tales are exiled
to live in the human world, the Big Bad Wolf
changes his ways and becomes Sheriff Bigby
Wolf, the lawkeeper of Fabletown.
After discovering the horrible murder of a
young woman, Bigby embarks on a desperate
hunt for a serial killer and along the way
finds himself digging deeper into the corruption
and organized crime at the heart of the Fable
community.
It's a tense story with plenty of interesting
characters, and it has the potential to be
a great crime thriller movie - with a talking
pig as a bonus.
Mass Effect
The stakes don't get much higher than trying
to prevent a race of synthetic beings from
wiping out every last trace of intelligent
life in the galaxy.
That's the task that falls to Commander Shepherd
in Bioware's Mass Effect trilogy, which is
set a long way into the future after humanity
has managed to tentatively establish itself
in the hierarchy of the Milky Way's alien
races.
This beautiful and expansive science fiction
epic captured the hearts of gamers, and with
the right director on board could capture
the hearts of moviegoers as well.
Grand Theft Auto
As we mentioned in our previous video, "Movies
You Didn't Know Were Influenced By Video Games",
Crank is modelled after the insanity of games
like Grand Theft Auto.
In turn, Grand Theft Auto was heavily influenced
by classic crime movies like Heat, Scarface
and Goodfellas.
So why not keep the cycle going by making
a Grand Theft Auto movie, complete with all
of the violence, satire and gleeful immorality
that made the video game series such a hit.
With a dream director like Michael Mann, Martin
Scorsese or Robert Rodriguez behind the wheel,
Grand Theft Auto could take over movie theaters
as successfully as it took over games consoles.
These are the video games that we would most
like to see on film, but are there any that
you think deserved to be on the list?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to watch
more videos like this one!